good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is start small over to
you Timothy Ferriss when I'm
procrastinating because there is
indecision and this is a particularly
dove procrastination in other words if I
have 10 things on my to-do list or 10
potential projects I could pursue what
to do in that situation and what I ask
myself is which one of these if done
will make the rest irrelevant or easier
this is a key question I ask all the
time which one of these will make all
the rest easier to do if done first or
all the rest I'm irrelevant
don't even need to do them that is how I
will then hone in on one piece of the
puzzle and this can be applied all over
the place but let's just say it's the
double of podcast it could be losing
weight all right you can see that's very
very amorphous we need timelines we need
an amount to lose and then you wanna
make it as small as possible so give you
a different example if you wanna if you
want to start flossing your teeth
who likes flossing their teeth pretty
much nobody so how do you start flossing
your teeth well you want to make it as
easy as possible to develop as part of
your routine to make it as automatic as
anything else that you do consistently
and you could borrow from say BJ Fogg
who's done a lot of research at Stanford
and elsewhere make it as small as
possible meaning in the beginning do
less than you are capable of doing so
this is another key when you think
something is too big or onerous so it's
too intimidating or it's too much of a
pain in the ass alright so for flossing
you might say I'm only gonna floss my
front two teeth that's three gaps that's
all you're gonna do and you want to make
it again as easy as possible so you
might use a Waterpik or you might use
those disposable flossing gadgets so you
don't have to do you know tourniquets on
your fingers which is also one of the
side effects of flossing that deters
people make it
easy as possible now this applies to a
lot more than flossing so I've talked to
many of the people for say tools of
titans people who are eight time New
York Times bestselling authors or
prolific musicians prolific music
producers like Rick Rubin who is
legendary and it all comes down to tiny
homework assignments so Rick if he has a
stuck artist for instance he will say
can you get me one word or one line that
you might like for this song that you're
working on like tomorrow is that
possible many many homework assignments
all right so with the creative project
in the beginning that's one it's related
to a piece of advice that I got from
Neil Strauss eight-time New York Times
bestselling author he's written for the
New York Times is written for the
rolling for Rolling Stone magazine and
that is lower your standards so he
doesn't believe in writer's block he
says your standards are just too high
you're creating performance anxiety for
yourself so the advice that I got from
another writer which matches with that
is two crappy pages per day so a lot of
people are like I'm gonna kill it I need
an ambitious goal let me do 1,500 words
2,000 words per day for this book I'm
working on well there's a very high
probability that you're gonna fall short
of that and then you will get
demoralized then you'll get intimidated
by the task and then you will start
procrastinating so make the hurdle make
the success threshold really really low
that's what I've done for my last three
books is two crappy pages per day that's
all I need if I don't end up using them
that's fine I just need to get out two
crappy pages what ends up happening with
the flossing with the writing with say
exercise if you're gonna exercise you're
making a new year's resolution don't
make it an hour a day four times a week
no no no no no ten and you if you don't
have an exercise habit five to ten
minutes at the gym three times a week
plenty and in all of those cases you
will feel successful because you've
checked your box for success and then
very often you will exceed that for
extra credit right okay well I'm already
at the gym I'll go for an extra ten
minutes well I'm already flossing my
teeth will do an extra four well I've
already hit my two pages but I'm feeling
great and I'm in the flow
I'll do 10 maybe I'll do 20 but it
prevents you from feeling like a failure
this is very very important that is what
do you rails a lot of people I think
it's really important for entrepreneurs
to think big and act small think big
it's your big mission your big vision
where you see yourself going the impact
you want to make on the world that five
year 20 year 100 year vision like the
one change that you want to make in the
world right what does that look like
that big picture it's great it's what
entrepreneurs genuinely are good I were
the dreamers so it's awesome think big
and act small tiny step make a phone
call send an email book an appointment
go to a conference read a book something
because here's what ends up happening to
so many people so many entrepreneurs get
stuck in this dreamland
right we're just constantly dreaming and
then we we think about our idea and then
it could take a lot of different turns
right and you wake up the next in psycho
that idea had yesterday was great but I
could add this to it and then it can
become here and then and what you do is
you keep adding to it and it becomes
this ginormous monster that then you can
never actually get started on because to
do it to build this to be way up here
you need venture capital funding and you
need a team and you need all these
resources and you need blah blah blah
blah blah and then because it becomes
this impossible huge perfect project you
don't do anything about it you just sit
on it and that's that's the book kills
so many entrepreneurs where it's great
to have that big thinking but you got to
do something
you're gonna take action even the
smallest way take action right away and
this is what I try to do every time I
come with a new idea I get a new idea I
want to start a YouTube channel I want
to you know by 10th company or whatever
it is that you want to do as soon as
I've decided that this is what I want to
do I find a way to test to start small
make make one video make one video like
you want to set a youtube channel you
decided great don't worry about the
camera don't worry about the lights
don't worry about the gear don't worry
about the editor don't worry about
anything take your phone and start
filming do something film your first
video it's gonna suck that's okay expect
it to suck and then mix one tomorrow
make one the next day make one
right thinking big this is still where
I'm going I know the vision I have I
know the kind of company I want to build
but do something every single day
don't let that perfection of an ideal
business prevent you from doing
something because no matter what you
start with it will not be perfect and
that's okay it's just a constant and
daily improvement to get better and
better and better and better I think
having five-year goals and ten-year
goals can be helpful to some people for
me as soon as I have a five-year goal a
ten-year goal I start thinking how we do
it right now I wanted to build a modern
home I wanted to build it from scratch
and as soon as I had that in my head I'm
thinking okay that that will happen
it'll happen like five years I can build
a house as soon as it came into my
consciousness I started acting on it I
started browsing researching properties
just as a side thing something fun to do
spare time looking at potential deals
you know do I knock down an existing
house do I just get land what do I do
and then I found the place here's a
place this is great
and then I decide to buy the place and
then I'm building a house like it just
happens as soon as something gets on my
consciousness that this is something I
want to do I just start doing it and I
think that's what lets people be
successful it wasn't that I have to find
the perfect place where I'm not gonna
get started just okay let me start let
me start researching let's see what
happens like experiment start small
tiniest steps forward is forward
progress you will never take the perfect
first step people ask me what's the best
first step in business there is no
perfect per step don't worry about the
first step just step and then take
another one and take another one and
you'll get better and you'll learn from
your mistakes and you'll model
successful people and you'll get better
each time but you need to start stepping
where people are too afraid to take that
first step because they won't be perfect
and they end up doing nothing and that's
what's gonna happen you'll get that
great idea and you just sit on it your
entire life then somebody else is gonna
make tons of money and huge impact off
of it so don't let that happen
big dreams big vision you know where you
want to go you know the kind of impact
you want to have and then daily
consistent action that sucks at the
beginning and improves on the consist
so the question today today is I'm
curious what is the smallest step that
you did today or will do today to
advance your big dream forward doesn't
matter what it is to some small step
that you are committing to taking today
or have already done today
congratulations to move your business
forward phone call email or reading the
resource whatever it is shared below
commit to it I want to see happen in the
comments I'm looking forward to seeing
what you have to say I also want to give
a quick shout out to Josh thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and doing that book review
on YouTube
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
[Music]
here's one really important point which
is that people get more ambitious over
time and when you know the founders of
Airbnb first came to us they were
delighted they had three users and if we
told them that someday they're going to
be running and you know 50 billion
dollar company whatever it's going to be
you know with more mics than anyone
touching in the world they would have
looked at us and said now you're crazy
like we don't want to work with you
because you know you're talking about so
I think there's this like pressure in
the last couple of years to have an
immediate vision about how you're going
to have this you know 10 I'll be done
with our company and no one honestly has
that in their in their first days Google
almost sold the coming four million
dollars they would have it's like the
offer came through you know like the I
like Zuckerberg very there and they were
sold so please look the out for a
billion dollars so um it's okay to like
become more ambitious as you go in fact
that's what should happen so what we
look for is people that have a kernel of
an idea that we believe can develop into
something huge but you can't focus on
that right away you have to focus on
delivering something great for a small
number of users first the way we talk
about this is that you know there's like
you can either create an initial product
but a lot of users really like or that
have small number of users really love
obviously you'd like to make something
that a lot of these is really love but
those ideas get taken by big companies
and we can't compete with them and so
you don't have to have a take over the
world plan on day one in fact very few
of the companies that we have been
involved with that have gone on to do it
thought they were going to initially
they just the founder had something
they're really passionate about they had
a plan and Scott was saying about
had some defensibility I just rose and
Rose advance from there I didn't prepare
myself to become a beauty guru it didn't
just happen it was something that I knew
fit for it myself I started filming on
YouTube on my webcam in college in my
room like just doing makeup tutorials
and now now like I work with L'Oreal and
I have like three companies that I'm a
CEO of so it's incredible how that all
happened because I had a passion and it
all started from the webcam and it
doesn't matter how small your beginnings
are it doesn't matter it just it just
all that matters is how big your passion
is Kaizen the study of Kaizen is one
step one little piece at a time that's
how do you eat an elephant one bite at a
time how do you win or run a thousand
mile race one step at a time when Japan
rebuilt after World War two they had to
adapt Kaizen because everything was
destroyed they looked at everything gone
they couldn't imagine trying to rebuild
Japan but what did they do they rebuilt
it one brick at a time one person at a
time one business at a time and it
turned into such a thriving country so
fast because they adapted Kaizen break
it up into small pieces you got a goal
take a bite today this moment when
you're done watching us right now go do
something towards your goal go send an
email call somebody say no say yes look
for a new job start the company just
create the URL if it's realistic go make
offers